this plant it's incredibly important
it's called coca and it mainly grows
here I'm right in the middle of it right
now right down here in southern Colombia
spending the day with the anti-narcotic
police who are looking for coca plants
to destroy coca is harvested by local
farmers shredded soaked in chemicals and
then cooked down into a paste this paste
is sold to cartels that use a series of
chemical processes to turn it into the
white powder we call cocaine which is
then shipped around the globe the
biggest portion ending up in the United
States but this isn't a story about
cartels or drug trafficking it's not
even a story about cocaine really this
is a story about this leaf and the
families who grow it out here deep in
the jungle it's these families who are
most affected by the cocaine economy and
it's these families who are caught in
the middle of Colombia's war on drugs
[Music]
[Music]
it's a Friday evening and I'm at a
police base that's right on the cusp of
Colombia's vast Amazon rainforest this
is Columbia at some of its most rural
and this region has historically been a
top coca producer in the country the
Intelligence Unit just got done briefing
us on the possible location of some
fields where coca is being harvested and
processed
we touchdown in a couple of spots but
only find abandoned farms no Coke
[Music]
but then after a few hours we spotted a
clearing deep in the jungle and rows and
rows of this light green coca leaf
[Music]
we land at this coca farm and find that
it's run by a family there are kids here
no guns no resistance just beside their
house is a shed where they've been
shredding the leaves which are now
soaking in chemicals the step before
they get sold off to the cartels and the
police aren't here to arrest them but
rather destroy their operation around
six months of work and very likely this
family's only income prospects right now
[Music]
the troops are clearly aware that
they've derailed this can also do it
okay not coming at all forget Obama
spoke well about you know I never stole
you as I see who's to you
[Music]
khoka farms like these fuel an
incredibly dangerous cocaine industry
which hurts tens of thousands of people
every year
so are these coca farmers the bad guys
if not why are we burning their shed and
if they're farmers why don't they just
grow another crop that isn't illegal
like pineapple or potato to find this
out I needed to go back into the jungle
but not in helicopters surrounded by
police but on my own look at this chart
this line shows coca production over
time and look what's happened since 2013
coca production has hit an all-time high
and the largest portion of the resulting
cocaine is ending up in the United
States which is the biggest cocaine
market in the world
far away in Colombia's capital Bogota
the government has been trying for
decades to curb this problem over the
years they've tried two main tactic for
eradicating cultwo cultivation the first
entails flying over these fields and
blanketing the whole area with this
plant killing chemical which is the same
as the roundup chemical that you use to
kill weeds in your yard the other
strategy is the one that I was a part of
sending out troops to manually destroy
the crops by uprooting it or burning the
sheds where the harvest is being
processed but there are some major
problems with these tactics first
spraying entire areas with this plant
killing chemical doesn't just affect the
coca fields it affects anything else it
touches killing food crops and the whole
rain forest that surrounds these fields
which is some of the most biodiverse
forests on earth the UN in the World
Health Organization also found that
these chemicals are potentially a cause
of cancer for the residents in these
areas so in 2015 the Colombian
government suspended the chemical
dumping strategy so now they're looking
for new solutions and last year they
implemented something called the crop
substitution program where the
government is going to pay 1 million
pesos per month which is like three
hundred and twenty seven dollars to any
farmer who eradicate their coca crop on
their own and starts growing a legal
crop like oranges or pineapple or yuca
after a very bumpy ride
I made it to a community that used to be
an epicenter for coca production but
last year they signed up for this crop
substitution program all the farmers in
the community signed a pact that they
would willingly transition to a legal
crop rocky open esta empezando call my
spirit are they built a model a coca and
Alesi plateau yet to produce during my
conversations the farmers kept throwing
math problems my way sounds like an
totally utterly poor Laura that's all
that y'all know or italic or Internal
Affairs leader in your class commit
critical reaction controlling the puck
my lord I'm an apartment kappa these
farmers live and die by prices prices of
farm supplies prices of seeds prices of
transportation and of course the price
that they can sell their crop keep in
mind that where I am is a place that is
almost completely absent of any central
government presence there aren't good
roads security reliable markets teníamos
watch Anthony plan to let opinion is
here and emotion Camille pinata Mucha
advice to a perdieron
in Opa garden Westerville CU l train in
transporting porque no leone pal
transport porque anuses in theologian as
um with the squawk oh no no no no Hannah
puja and so when you start to do the
math of all the costs associated with
growing something else it just doesn't
add up
which is why coca thrives out here will
change you and of course yeah PhD so
basically on your drawings okay now
as this farming community tries to
survive outside the cocaine economy
they're experiencing what it feels like
to be just another rural community cut
off from Columbia's mainstream economies
the panic Okayama at all it was I don't
[ __ ] know I cook I know my brother
the government might be able to pay
these farmers to get rid of their coca
but without roads markets banks and
connections to the rest of the country
these new economies will not take root
you put up with so now think back to
that family who shed the police burned
down earlier they live an hour's
helicopter ride from any town so they
don't really have other economic options
beyond coca which is really the only
commodity that they can transport to a
market porque si monsoon acuerdo con el
gobierno fear mommy please hoy tenemos
el mia que el gobierno no complicated my
Ava's que mr. Campion or bail bond a
rainy season
[Music]
though I did find one family that
represents a success story for the crop
substitution program they mainly grow
passion fruit but they also grow corn
yuca tomatoes peppers and raised animals
[Music]
passion fruit juice they switched from
coca last year after an entire lifetime
of growing it and it's gone really well
for them but you'll notice that this
family has a huge plot of land most of
these farmers out here don't have that
big plot of land and they don't have the
ability to cultivate so many crops to
replace their coca so as of now all of
these solutions continue to be band-aids
dumping roundup on these fields manually
eradicating even the crop substitution
the only lasting solution will come when
the government invests in connecting
these communities to the rest of the
country so that legal economies can
actually take root here that's going to
take time and money but until the
government does this long slow work
farmers will continue to find a way to
participate in the only economy that
pays
[Music]
all right that's it borders Columbia is
over thank you for watching I learned so
much about this country reporting these
videos and I hope you did too
everything from the border up to the
hippos and then learning about this new
style of music and I even got to go eat
some fruit in Bogota which was really
fun next step for me is I'm going to
start looking into the next locations
for borders so stay tuned for that and
also I should tell you that Vox just
started a membership program for $5 a
month you can get access to a bunch of
behind the scenes stuff I did this
extended interview with this drummer
that I met reporting episode 3 of
borders and you can see that whole thing
if you become a member so you can go
check that out on the youtube channel
and thanks for watching borders
[Music]